a coyote got trapped in a bathroom he I
want to say it was in South Carolina or
North Carolina there Wildman they in
this bathroom and these guys have to get
it out of the bathroom and sitting on
the sink it's crazy they had to use one
of them long poles that the the jack
dogs you know they grab around the neck
you see it mmm
I knew was one of those places in
Nashville yeah I could see that dude
it's a cool little video but it's weird
like those little [ __ ] are everywhere
now they are everywhere
well raccoons are really dangerous you
they're always doing you know Jerry's
helmet
the Nashville Music Hall and that's
beautiful so they're in this Hall in a
Boat Show look at him he's chillin it's
a very photogenic
how weird so what they did was they
captured it and they said that if they
brought it to an animal shelter they
would have euthanized it so instead they
captured it and let it loose in the
woods woods cool do you have any animals
that you don't tell people that you have
like any secret animal I keep a lot of
giraffes I can see you having something
now have you thought about it oh you
start piranhas allegedly and what do
they keep in a tank you know you keep me
in a tank you know you used to be able
to buy a human skeleton online just have
a human skeleton at the bottom of my
piranha tank really where does that you
buy a skeleton and what can you do with
it I don't think you can anymore I bet
you can't buy him anymore he used to be
able to just buy human skeleton how long
can you keep it the whole time forever
who was it um here's the funny thing I
got rid of it and we'll get rid of him
like mammal throw away this human
skeleton is some questions may come with
this you would think it'd be like a
Cabbage Patch doll like he comes with a
little birth certificate we bird it
which is even worse probably and then
people are gonna be like what the [ __ ]
someone someone got killed here yeah
someone's gonna find it someday go what
the [ __ ] it's gonna be a giant mystery
it sounds fun I always love mystery man
the thing is somebody might have died
like they might have somebody might have
killed somebody and sold their bones
it's probably one of those on real oh my
what does it say is that let me look at
this a male from India in good condition
12 teeth present the rest broken missing
there is lipping on the lumbar vertebra
what that's five thousand dollars you
could buy a [ __ ] human skeleton holy
[ __ ]